another question from james what
software stack does launch use which
apps are integral to your team success
and why
what are the most impressive software
apps right now slack notion zoom etc
uh obviously we're big fans of slack and
notion
um and salesforce and
gosh you know we just use every piece of
sass over you can imagine
out there sauna monday we we we use it
all
we love it all um i just am in love with
the fact
that software is so affordable and gets
constantly better we use squarespace
we're using sendgrid and twilio i mean
some of these are sponsors past and
present
um some of them have never been sponsors
but it's just a really great way to
make your people bionic what you need to
do is look at all the software and make
sure you don't get sass burn out in your
organization
where you know i think at one point we
may have gotten up to like 14 sas
products and we looked at and said you
know what
let's cut these two or three because we
can
do that in this core piece of software
so as an example
google docs is something we use but we
don't like google docs
for doing what we do in notion notion so
much better than just a
a doc here on the side that nobody has
access to so
a lot of what we use google docs for
we're out of but we still love google
sheets
uh we still love error tables so we're
still using
you know some select ones and then i
also like people to
uh you know roll their own and spin
their own and and
evaluate these things on their own so if
somebody wants to use airtable in my
team and another person is in love with
google sheets i'll let them you know
pursue their muse and then eventually
you know uh you know we'll pick one or
if we're not we just let them use both
because
i care about results if you happen to as
a chef like a certain knife
and i happen to like a different brand
of knife in today's world
it's okay for us to use two different
knives in the old days they'd be like oh
no we have to be on this platform
as an example uh we love dell monitors i
love dell laptops and computers
i love using chrome i am off of mac os
because it's such a disaster and
productivity killer
it's got so much craft and machines are
for three or four times more expensive
than chrome machines
and two times more expensive than
windows machines so i've gone all in
with chrome and i'm actually warming up
to windows again
and i got this dell chromebook and it
has all my ports back on it
and i'm like oh my god i got all my
ports back
i have a i have an ethernet port in my
laptop
i have a memory card in my laptop i have
a sim card in my laptop
i've got a usbc and two regular usbs
i've got an hdmi on my laptop no more
dongles
i'm back to having adele and i love it
so uh shout out to dell uh and shout out
to people rolling their owns and
in our video department we're we're now
realizing we can buy
two dell machines for the price of an
equivalent apple machine
so we can literally or we can buy a
machine that has twice as much memory
and twice as much storage
and 25 more cpu power than what we would
pay for that
insane mac pro not the macbook pro but
the mac pro tower like why would you
ever buy that when you could buy a dell
that's just souped up with a ton of
memory
makes no sense so i think you have to
look at the bottom line as well
and negotiate with your stats providers
too because they will play ball if it's
too expensive
great question